[Music]
from conflict zones to the streets of
Europe EU government institutions and
firms increasingly use private security
companies or PSCs to beef our protection
of military diplomatic and civilian
installations and buildings in 2013
there were some 40,000 pscs in europe
with 1.5 million contractors in a global
industry valued at 200 billion US
dollars in 2016 it's controversial some
questioned the very idea of having
through outsourced security needs to the
private sector para nosotros los alamos
s for limit our inclusive sack our la
compañía frivolous vilambit o la difensa
cos competent espacio de los Estados
nothing recent scandals have raised
serious concerns PhDs have been accused
of committing human rights violations
and even causing casualties reporter
Yildiz Altman says we need to have you
standards in place more democratic
control over the use of pfcs and
clarification as their responsibility a
parliament can achieve wants PSCs to
stay clear of military combat tasks
adhere to strict codes of conduct and
have the staff vetted any PSR also
calling for international legally
binding legislation to regulate
activities of PSCs
you